all right let's get to the draft chris
i'm gonna give you the first pick the
week six matchup draft who do you have
well
i i i guess i gotta go to the rogers and
brady matchup i mean i am i know they're
not against each other but they're very
aware of who's on the other sideline and
the implications and how much it'll be
talked about green bay is in the
conversation or maybe is the best team
in the nfc
tampa is a team that's on everybody's
radar to say well watch out for them
they got a ton of talent all over the
field
i mean it seems like brady's getting
more and more comfortable in the offense
roger's been on fire all year long this
will be one of their tougher tests
because this bucks d is real especially
this pass rush but i am excited to see
that and i know they're not on the field
at the same time but uh like i said
these are two legends and it'll be worth
the price of admission
that that was my first pick as well
aaron rodgers getting a chance to go
toe-to-toe with the guy who's the goat
simply because he was in the right place
at the right time at least that's what
rogers must be thinking at some level
when he's sitting around sipping scotch
and or tequila and maybe both at the
same time maybe mixing the scotch and
the tequila uh how about this one uh and
and uh whoever plays quarterback for the
49ers may need some scotch and tequila
before during and after the game aaron
donald versus whoever gets the short
straw for the 49ers on sunday night
whoever it is congratulations and
condolences all in one you're the
starting quarterback against this guy
who had four sacks and seems to be
reaching a level of performance we've
never seen from a defensive lineman in
league history especially in the
interior defensive lineman so i feel bad
for jimmy garoppolo or cj beathard or
nick mullins or whoever they sign to the
roster and say here's the ball go have
fun with this this guy who's going to be
coming at you every time you drop back
yeah yeah that that that's going to be a
scary one for the 49ers especially you
know they got two backups in there and
in the middle of their line right now
you know so that's that's an issue it's
yeah it's western richburg's not in its
center they got brunskill at right guard
that that's going to be a mismatch to
where shanahan
who we know is smart
you know that's something to watch out
for
he is going to have to formulate the
game plan around like okay i can't leave
these guys one-on-one i want to run this
play but i can't do it because i can't
trust this guy i want to run this pass
protection but i can't do it because i'm
going to leave him one-on-one with a guy
that's lesser than him so he's gonna
have to be creative in formations and
and everything to make sure he helps
these guys out a little bit and i hear
you big game for the 49ers uh they're
reeling and i'm a little worried about
them as you can tell um i'm going with
the other quarterback match up i mean i
got it my boy blue and my homie my homie
uh you know two of the most
exciting young quarterbacks you know in
the game right now i know lamar
jackson's in that conversation but i you
know for my money again josh allen has
entered the top five quarterback in
football conversation he is for me right
now no doubt in the top five from what
we've seen through the first five weeks
of the year so uh their play making
ability their ability to do things off
schedule their right arms again i think
their awareness of like whoa that guy's
pretty freaking talented
and i think that'll add to the match up
the throw off who can throw it farther
who could throw it harder all those
things uh i think that's going to add a
little extra juice to the bill's chiefs
game
i had another one from that game i'm not
going to go there i'd rather go to a
different game but andy reid versus sean
mcdermott reed once fired mcdermott is a
defensive coordinator that's right
philadelphia is something that i'm sure
sean mcdermott still remembers to this
day next one for me
how about the browns defensive line
against the steelers offensive line
uh and you also could go miles gary
brown's offensive line against the
steelers defensive line right but i
think that brown's defensive line has
been underrated this year they have done
some good things and can that steelers
offensive line which isn't as good as it
used to be hold up long enough to give
ben roethlisberger the time he needs to
operate the offense that could be where
this game is won it's always one of the
trenches but on both sides in this game
yeah how those offensive lines do
against very good front sevens is going
to be a huge factor yeah it agreed yeah
and you're i mean you're right
cleveland's d-line line's real they're i
mean sheldon richardson's awesome inside
i mean miles garrett we've talked about
them a lot during the show olivier
vernon you know they got some other
other guys who fill in
that are also very good you know role
players along there so uh i'm with you
and then that added dynamic of miles
garrett and everything that happened
that is going to be fun to watch they'll
be in some intensity in that game
there's no doubt and i'm with you there
you know the trenches is going to be
interesting in that matchup cleveland
can they move pittsburgh to run the ball
can pittsburgh pass protect enough to
throw the ball i think that's what it
might come down to
all right i'm going to go wence versus
the ravens secondary that's the one i'm
i'm
interested to see how that plays out
because i don't think there's any weapon
on the philadelphia offense that is
going to scare baltimore marcus peters
or marlon humphrey two of the best in
the game and
i just can once reign it in with the
baltimore defense that's going to do a
lot of crazy stuff blitzes have people
on them you know what's it going to be
is going to be able to capitalize and
make some big plays or is it going to be
oh man he threw three interceptions and
really let the game get away from him i
could see it going either way here so
ravens secondary versus wence is my last
pick
my last pick goes to the last game of
the week the cardinals and the cowboys
it's cliff kingsbury and kyler murray
versus texas it reminds me of a few
weeks ago when otto beckham jr comes
back to texas he knows it well from his
time with the giants
you've got miles garrett who grew up
near the stadium you've got baker
mayfield back there i just feel like the
cardinals coming into that big spot that
big stage coming back to texas that's
going to give them an extra lift or
maybe mess with them a little bit
because it didn't work out so well for
cliff kingsbury at texas tech but i like
that element to this game that a couple
of guys with strong connections to texas
coming back to show chris what they can
do all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports